if I said to you the word cob cephei or
Co Fifi or I don't really know how it's
pronounced would that mean anything to
you well if it doesn't it will by the
end of this segment a Donald Trump's
bizarre behavior is continuing to raise
more mental health questions and we've
done a number of videos sort of calling
into question Donald Trump's emotional
stability and we've talked about his
reading ability or lack thereof we
talked about possible early signs of
dementia we've talked about possible
personality disorders and a number of
tweets and videos from and of Donald
Trump over the last few days are again
fueling concerns about sort of all three
of these issues the one up making the
big headlines is the one with the
misspelling of I guess maybe the word
coverage as cough fa but that's not
actually the most disturbing one of
these examples let's start to dig in
first of all Donald Trump tweeted not
long ago yesterday just over 24 hours
ago a sort of incoherent sentence about
something relating to Russia and fake
news which I'll put up on the screen for
you saying quote Russian officials must
be laughing at the US and how a lame
excuse for why the Dems lost the
election has taken over the fake news I
would love to see one of those syntax
trees diagramming this sentence from a
linguistic point of view but we're not
going to do that right now that aside
this is a communication from one of the
most powerful powerful people in the
world
despite vision inventions of many people
who are concerned about him and being
being in that role this is not exactly
an utterance of a mentally coherent
individual a Yale University
psychiatrist bandy Lee said last week to
salon.com quote I've been thinking from
the very beginning that he exhibits many
signs of mental impairment this
situation has come to such a critical
level what we're seeing is a creation of
his own reality a reality that will meet
Trump's own
emotional needs and the need to impose
that reality on others could what
psychiatrists bandy Lee is pointing out
here explain the James Comey firing
which is completely imploded on Trump as
a potential way to stem the tide of the
Russia Trump collusion investigations
could this explain those strange
comments about James Comey better hope
there are no recordings of our meeting
could this explain the haphazard leaking
of secret and classified information
so not only Russians in the Oval Office
but two Filipino president Rodrigo
Duterte
could this explain arriving in Israel
and saying we just got back from the
Middle East could this explain pushing
the president of Montenegro all of this
very very strange and adding to these
concerns are a few seconds of video from
Donald Trump's appearance with Israeli
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu there
was a tweet that was sent out from paste
Latin who is a an individual who tweets
I don't even have to give you his
credentials but pointing out quote
reports say that Trump became confused
and didn't know where he was in Israel
and in the middle of a press conference
wandered off we actually have video of
this and watch not only Donald Trump in
this video who if you're not watching
and just listening does seem to be sort
of disoriented and watch Benjamin
Netanyahu's reaction when this is going
on very short video take a look at this
my story
Trump truly looking disoriented and
confused and sort of unstable on his
feet with regard to where he was there
are folks on the inside of the White
House saying Trump is is getting worse
emotionally Trump is getting worse
mentally and according to a quote source
close to him
Trump has sort of receded into his own
world since rhetoric returning from the
Middle East an anonymous source close to
Trump said to CNN quote he now lives
within himself which is a dangerous
place for Donald Trump to be I see him
emotionally withdrawing video from a
Memorial Day ceremony in Arlington
Virginia you see Donald Trump smiling
laughing dancing and head-banging and
making some strange mouth movement that
I guess could be at least partially
singing along to the national anthem
but again Trump's demeanor I'm going to
play this for you it doesn't really seem
coherent with the somber and solemn
atmosphere of a Memorial Day event take
a look at this video
ladies and gentlemen please join the
united states air force and anything
into national anthem
[Music]
and then last but not least cough fa
which is the funniest but also sort of
the most benign at 1206 a.m. Eastern
Time last night early this morning 10:06
p.m. mountain time
president Trump treed tweeted a very
bizarre sentence fragment despite the
constant negative press Cobb's FA and
Twitter exploded Trump minutes later
replaced it with another tweet saying
who can figure out the true meaning of
cob fifi and joy
I assume that he met negative press
coverage it is funny the memes are
hilarious it's all hilarious but really
this is just a small thing the real
concern is the growing signs of
emotional and mental instability
cognitive instability of the President
of the United States and and you know
what I'll tell you it would make much
more sense that Trump's bizarre behavior
with diplomats and world leaders is
explained by cognitive decline or issues
than him just being completely in over
his head with the presidency which let's
be honest we sort of know him to be